so Megan obviously it's 50 years for
this franchise what's like being
involved with a series like that um it's
it's pretty special there I don't know
if there's any other shows we've been on
the air for 50 years I don't quote me on
that but yeah it's it's it's iconic and
it feels really nice to be a part of a
show that means so much to people that
people have grown up watching and yeah
I'm very honored tell me how are you
gonna honor the 50th anniversary so for
the 50th anniversary we are retelling
the story of the original pilot of
Hawaii five-o cocoon very cool tell us
what should fans be excited about coming
up in season 9 um
fans should be excited about season 9
because it's more of your favorite
characters and action sequences and a
lot of special little surprises just
because it's such a big year because of
the 50th anniversary of the show lots of
really cool guest stars it's going to be
a ride so last year was your first year
this year you're returning what's it
like coming back it's great it's great
coming back it's uh I have a baby now I
don't I'm kidding it's it's been amazing
coming back it's just nice to see all my
friends again and it's it's an easier
transition because now I know the island
pretty well and yeah I know all the good
places to eat so I'm set what do you do
with your free time well you have to um
I mean I usually on my free time I
usually try to travel back to LA because
I have a place there and I you know
watch a lot of TV and I take photographs
and yeah I mean like kind of I'm kind of
low-key I keep a low profile so nine
seasons for any show is incredible what
is it about Hawaii five-o that has made
it
so successful this long you know I I'm
not sure what the but the special
ingredient is because there are so few
shows that have achieved this much but
you know I mean I think it's just the
kind of stories that they tell it's
stuff that actually is happening in the
world it's current it has a great cast
it has a great crew and things just
function properly here so it is sort of
a recipe for success yeah I mean it's a
that's actually kind of what are the
coolest things about being on the show
is seeing that you know a lot of the
crew most of the crew have been here
since the beginning so they've all
really grown up together you know
they've got married they've gotten
divorce they've gotten married again and
I've never seen a group of people who've
gone through that much they've really
lived an entire life so it's pretty
special
YV fall in love with playing you know
time so he's fun she's just she is
really good at her job and she you know
doesn't really do things by the book she
takes chances she's kind of reckless but
uh you know she's brave and she's fun
and yeah I like her I like her